[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم عثمان اي
فرح وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من رام الله وهذه
الصور تزامنا مع تصعيد اسرائيلي في ملف
الاستيطان بالضفه الغربيه تمثل اليوم في
اقامه السلطات الاحتلال بيوتا متنقله على
اراضي بلده لبن الشرقيه جنوبا نابلس
لتهيئتها لاقامه بؤره استيطانيه جديده
وهذه صور من الخرطوم التي تعيش على وقع
معارك محتدمه في مناطق عده من بينها ام
درمان التي شهدت قصفا من قبل الجيش
السوداني على مواقع لقوات الدعم السريع
ومن نيو فاوند لاند في كندا نتابع هذه
الصور المباشره تزامنا مع اعلان خبر
السواحل الامريكي ان الحطام الذي عثر عليه
قرب موقع للسفينه تايتنك يعود للغواصه
السياحيه المفقوده منذ صباح الاحد قباله
كندا وقد اعلن خبر السواحل ان خمسه اشخاص
كانوا على متنها هم الان في اعداد الموتى
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
يوم اخر من التصعيد في الضفه عنوانه
الاستيطان والمستوطنون على وقع هجمات
لمستوطنين على قريه جالود جنوبيه نابلس
الاحتلال يبدا باقامه بؤرتين على اراضي
قرى فلسطينيه في نابلس ورام الله وخلال
سته اشهر ثلاث تشكيل حكومه نتنياهو يسجل
البناء الاستيطاني معدلات غير مسبوقه بحسب
تقرير اسرائيلي
في خضم معارك داريا في مناطق عده في
الخرطوم نائب رئيس مجلس السياده يؤكد رفض
مبادره ايجاد ويتهمها بالسعي لادخال قوات
دوليه الى السودان
تؤكد تاجيل محادثات جده بسبب اخفاق الصيغه
الحاليه في تحقيق اهدافها
تزامنا مع هجمات اوكرانيه مكثفه جنوبا
روسيا تتهم اوكرانيا باستهداف جسر يربط
شبه جزيره القرم بمقاطعه خيرسون شويغو
يقول ان اوكرانيا بدات بتقليص نشاطها بعد
اسبوعين من الهجوم المضاد وازيلينسكي يتهم
موسكو بالترتيب لهجوم على محطه النوويه
ويقول للجزيره ان العالم يجب ان يمنع
تكرار ما حدث في سد كخوفك
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه لقائنا
على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق
خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
رئيس الوزراء الهندي في الولايات المتحده
احتفاء نادر وتشديد على اولويات الشراكه
لا يحجبان الانتقادات لسجل الضيف الحقوقي
[موسيقى]
البدايه من الاراضي الفلسطينيه وتصعيد في
اكثر من جهه لكن عنوانه الابرز هو
الاستيطان والمستوطنون فقد افاد الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني بنقل جريحين للمستشفى في
قريه جالوت جنوب شرقي نابلس في الضفه
الغربيه بعد اصابتهما باعيره الناريه
اطلقها جنود الاحتلال خلال اعتداء
مستوطنين على مدخل القريه وكان اهالي قريه
جالود وبمساعده من جيرانهم في بلده قريوت
قد تصدوا لمستوطنين حاولوا اقتحام قريتهم
والاعتداء عليهم
وقبل ذلك اقامه مستوطنون اسرائيليون فجر
اليوم بؤره استيطانيه جديده على اراضي
قريه ام صفا شمال غرب رام الله بحمايه
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وقال مروان صباح
رئيس مجلس القريه ان عشرين مستوطنا
استولوا على ارض وسطها ونصب قياما واضاف
صباح ان قوات الاحتلال نصبت حاجزا عسكريا
عند مدخل ام صفا وفتشت مركبات الفلسطينيين
ودققت في هوياتهم
كما اقامت سلطات الاحتلال سته بيوت متنقله
على اراضي بلده اللبن الشرقيه جنوب نابلس
على الطريق الواصل بين مدينتي نابلس ورام
الله وافاد مصدر للجزيره بان الاحتلال جرف
ارضا تقع على بعد كيلومترين من مكان عمليه
اطلاق النار عند مستوطنه عيني والتي قتل
فيها اربعه مستوطنين امس الاول لاقامه
بؤره استيطانيه
وقد اظهر التقارير اسرائيليه ان البناء
الاستيطانيه في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
تضاعف وسجل ارقاما قياسيه جديده جديده منذ
تشكيل الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه برئاسه
بنيامين نتنياهو قبل سته اشهر تعزيز
البناء الاستيطاني يستمروا رغم تحذيرات
امريكيه من ان الاستيطان هو عقبه امام
السلام بحسب وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
تفاصيل توسع الاستيطاني في الضفه الغربيه
نتابعها في التقرير التالي
مجموعه من المستوطنين يتسللون فجرا الى
قريه ام الصفا بين رام الله ونابلس بحمايه
جيش الاحتلال
ينصبون خياما ويعلنون الاستيلاء على
المكان هكذا تنشا المستوطنات في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه قبل ذلك بساعات تقر حكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو توسعه مستوطنه عيلي
الواقعه قرب ام الصفا في قرار انتقامي
بوصف الحكومه نفسها ردا على عمليه شهدتها
المستوطنه
المستوطنه اقيمت اصلا على اراضي بلدات
فلسطينيه جرفها الاحتلال
لا تخفي الحكومه الاسرائيليه الاكثر تطرفا
دعمها ايديولوجيا الاستيطان اظهر التقارير
اسرائيليه جديده ان البناء الاستيطانيه في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله سجل ارقاما قياسيه
جديده منذ تشكيل الحكومه الحاليه قبل سته
اشهر فمنذ مطلع العام الحالي صادقه
الحكومه على اقامه اكثر من ثلاثه عشر الف
وحده مقابل عشره الاف وحده تمت المصادقه
عليها عام 2020
ويبحث ما يسمى المجلس الاعلى للتخطيط
والاستيطان الاسبوع المقبل التصديق على
بناء اكثر من 4000
و500 وحده استيطانيه جديده في مناطق
مختلفه في الضفه الغربيه
ويقدم الاستيطان مساحات واسعه من اراضي
الضفه الغربيه ويعيش اكثر من 700 الف
مستوطن موزعين على اكثر من 300 مستوطنه
وبؤره استيطانيه في المناطق المصنفه جيم
بحسب اتفاق اوسلو وكان الكنيسه الاسرائيلي
صادق قبل بضعه اسابيع على الغاء قانون فك
الارتباط وسمح بالتالي بعوده المستوطنين
الى اربع مستوطنات شمال الضفه وهي
جانيم وكاديم وحومش وسنور
[موسيقى]
هذا وقد قال مندوب فلسطين في الامم
المتحده ان السلطه الفلسطينيه طالبت مجلس
الامن بتوفير حمايه دوليه مؤقته والضغط
لوقف كافه الانشطه الاستيطانيه والتصعيد
الاسرائيليه في الضفه الغربيه
لا يمكن القول ان هجمات المستوطنين في
اليومين الماضيين غير مسبوقه ما حدث في
ترمس عيا يتكرر في قرى فلسطينيه كثيره وفق
احصائيات هيئه مقاومه الاستيطان
الفلسطينيه فان المستوطنين نفذوا اكثر من
500 اعتداء في شهر مايو الماضي وحده في
تلك القريه هاجم المستوطنون الناس بحمايه
جيش الاحتلال فاحرقوا عشرات المنازل
والسيارات محمود
عباس
بعد ساعات قليله وصل رئيس الوزراء
الفلسطيني الى قريه ترمس عيا يقاطع مسن
فلسطيني المؤتمر الصحفي للمسؤول الفلسطيني
ترتفع هذه الاصوات وتطرح هذه الاسئله
وبحمل المسؤوليه
عندكم 70 الف مسلح
يحدث ذلك كله في قريه على بعد بضعه
كيلومترات من وسط رام الله هناك حيث
يتمركز الالاف من عناصر الامن الفلسطيني
ففي المدن الفلسطينيه قرابه 70 الف عنصر
امني تابعين للسلطه باجهزتها المختلفه
بشكل اساسي تتشكل المؤسسه الامنيه
الفلسطينيه من اجهزه الامن الوقائي
والمخابرات والاستخبارات العسكريه والشرطه
باقسامها والامن الوطني تقول منظمات
المجتمع المدني الفلسطيني ان اجهزه الامن
تستحوذ على اكثر من 20% من ميزانيه السلطه
متفوقه بذلك على قطعي التعليم والصحه
يتوزع عناصر الامن في المناطق المصنفه الف
بحسب اتفاق اوسلو وهي مراكز المدن في
الضفه بشكل اساسي والمناطق المحاذيه لها
تلك مناطق لا تشكل اكثر من 15% من مساحه
الضفه الغربيه لكن يعيش فيها اكثر من 85%
من الفلسطينيين في الضفه بهذا الشكل يمنع
على اجهزه الامن التحرك خارج هذه المناطق
الا بتنسيق مع سلطات الاحتلال
في الوقت نفسه يفرض الاحتلال وفق
الاتفاقيات مع السلطه ليس فقط التنسيق
الامني الذي توجه له اصوات فلسطينيه
انتقادات واستنكارات بل ان تلك الاتفاقيات
تفرض ايضا نوعا معينا من تسليح الامن
الفلسطيني وهو سلاح محدود بالاسلحه
الخفيفه لكن الاهم بالنسبه لمراقبين كثر
ان الامر متعلق بعقيده هذه الاجهزه لا بما
تملكه من قدرات عسكريه عقيده اعيد تاهيلها
بعد الانتفاضه الثانيه اذ اشرف الجنرال
الامريكي
حينها على اعاده تشكيل الاجهزه الامنيه
على قاعده اعاده رسم العقيده الامنيه لها
ومنذ ذلك الحين لم تتكرر مشاهد الاشتباكات
بين عناصر الامن الفلسطيني وقوات الاحتلال
ففي الانتفاضه الثانيه انخرطت الاجهزه
الامنيه الفلسطينيه في القتال وواجهت
الاجتياح الاسرائيلي
قصف الاحتلال مقر الاجهزه الامنيه وقتل
واعتقل العشرات من عناصرها منذ ذلك الحين
لم تنسحب اسرائيل من الضفه الغربيه ولم
توقف اقتحاماتها لكن الاجهزه الامنيه
الفلسطينيه توقفت عن مواجهه هذه
الاقتحامات
من بيت لحم ينضم الينا سهيل خليليه مدير
وحده مراقبه الاستيطان في معهد الابحاث
التطبيقيه اريج استاذ سهيل اهلا وسهلا بك
الاحتلال يقدم اراض شاسعه من الضفه
الغربيه في عمليات الاستيطان هذه التي بدا
باختصار مراحلها وبالاسراع بها وبتعزيزها
فما الذي سيتبقى من الضفه اذا كانت الامر
على هذه الوتيره وبهذه الطريقه
مساء الخير
نعم هذا سؤال وسؤال محق لان يعني ما يخطط
له الاحتلال بشكل او باخر هو الاستيلاء
الكامل على كل ما يسمى اراضي دوله وهذه
المساحه تشكل حوالي 40% من مساحه الضفه
الغربيه او بالاحرى 70% من المساحه
المسماه جيم اي هي المساحه اللي خارج
نطاق المنطقه الف وباء
فالاستيلاء على سبعين بالمئه من مساحه
المنطقه المسماه جيم يعني ليس مجرد هو
منطقه المستوطنات ولكن البؤر الاستيطانيه
شبكه الطرق الالتفافيه منطقه الاغوار
بمعظمها
وايضا اهم من ذلك منطقه شرقيه القدس
والحدود ايضا وطبعا كل ما هو موجود في ذلك
من مصادر طبيعيه وتحديدا الابار الجوفيه
من المياه وغير ذلك والاراضي الزراعيه
فنعم السؤال ما الذي سيتبقى
والجواب هو لن يبقى الكثير حتى ان ما
يتبقى من المنطقه جيم والتي ممكن اعطائها
للفلسطينيين لن تكون
متصله
ومربوطه مع بعضها البعض ولكن لا يعني
الاحتلال يعني يخطط الى فصل الضفه الغربيه
من خلال شبكه طرق خاصه
ستربط المناطق الفلسطينيه مع بعضها البعض
وبالتالي ستكون التجمعات الفلسطينيه
مفصوله عن بعضها البعض تربطها شبكات طرق
يسيطر عليها الاحتلال ولن يتسنى لها
التواصل مع بعضها الجغرافيه وما هو ان
الاحتلال سيد الموقف من الاعتداءات
المتكرره مئات الاعتداءات ايضا على
المواطنين الفلسطينيين في ترمسيه على سبيل
المثال واحراق المنازل ما هو الهدف من من
هذه الاعتداءات المستمره
نعم الهدف فيما يتعلق بموضوع الاعتداءات
شوف الاحتلال يخطط ومنذ مده من الزمن الى
تحويل هذا الصراع من صراع ما بين جيش محتل
ومدنيين فلسطينيين الاحتلال يحاول ان يعيد
رسم
شكل هذا الصراع بان يجعل هذا الصراع ما
بين المستوطن كمدني يصور المستوطن كمدني
مقابل مدني فلسطيني هذا يحمل سلاح وهذا
يحمل سلاح فبالتالي يحاول ان يعيد تشكيل
ورسم هذا الصراع ما بين
مدنيين فلسطينيين وما يسميهم مدنيين اللي
هم المستوطنين الاسرائيليين وهذه لنقل
الصوره هذه الى العالم وبالتالي تغيير
الفكره الفكره العامه بان هناك احتلال من
جيش مدرب منظم يهاجم المدنيين الفلسطينيين
والاطفال وغير ذلك طبعا الاحتلال يحاول ان
يراوغ مثل ما فعل دائما فيما يتعلق بشكل
هذا الصراع هو يفعل ما يريد الان ما هي
الخيارات الفلسطينيه لمواجهه كل ذلك
يعني
خياراتنا طبعا لن اقول محدوده ولكن يعني
خياراتنا هي بيدنا يعني اول خيار ممكن ان
نجابه به ما يقوم به الاحتلال هو طبعا
اعاده اللحمه الفلسطينيه مع بعضها البعض
هذا المطلوب على الاقل في هذه المرحله لان
الاحتلال اذا ما اعاد الفلسطينيين لحمتهم
سيعيد ترتيب اوراقه لان لان ذلك سيربك
الاحتلال بشكل اكيد
وبشكل مباشر
بالاضافه الى ذلك علينا ان نفعل اكثر من
جبهه على الصعيد الدولي من خلال تحريك
الدبلوماسيه الفلسطينيه بشكل اوسع وايضا
استغلال
العامل العربي يعني يجب ان نستغل العامل
العربي بمعنى ان هناك جهاد دوليه عربيه
لها
افاق لها يعني يد واسعه وي تطول
الامم المتحده وغيرها من
المراكز الدوليه نستطيع ان نتحرك من خلال
هذه مجابهه ما يفعل الاحتلال واليوم
نستطيع نحن كعرب بشكل عام ان نشكل جبهه
ليس فقط على دوله الاحتلال ولكن على غيرهم
من الدول الاخرى شكرا جزيلا لك من بيت
اللحم سهيل خليليه مدير وحده مراقبه
الاستيطان في معهد الابحاث التطبيقيه
[موسيقى]
الى التطورات في السودان فعلى وقع معارك
ضاريه في مناطق عده في الخرطوم تتعقد
مسارات الحل في اكثر من اتجاه مساعده وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه
للشؤون الافريقيه قالت ان محادثات السودان
تاجلت لعدم خروج الصيغه بطريقه
المطلوبه اما نائبه رئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني مالك عجار فقال ان بلاده ترفض
مبادره الاتحاد الافريقي بسبب تعليق عضويه
السودان ووصف عكار مبادره الاجهاد بمبادره
احتلال وقال انها تسعى لادخال قوات دوليه
الى السودان
يعلو صوت السلاح في السودان وتتعثر
الوساطات مساعده وزير خارج الامريكي
للشؤون الافريقيه قالت ان محادثات السودان
اجلت لعدم خروج صيغه بالطريقه المطلوبه
شارك وزير الخارجيه
ومباشر في مباحثات الاربعاء وركزنا جهودنا
على ثلاثه محاور الاول هو العمل
الدبلوماسي الطارئ مع شركائنا السعوديين
اذ عملنا لتحقيق وقف لاطلاق النار والسماح
بايصال المساعدات الانسانيه لكننا اجلنا
تلك المحادثات لان الصيغه لم تنجح
بالطريقه التي نريدها ياتي حديث المسؤوله
الامريكيه بعد ان انتهت هدنه من ثلاثه
ايام دون ان تتحدد ملامحه هدنه اخرى ودون
ان يلوح في الافق اي امل في اختراق
دبلوماسي يزداد افق الدبلوماسيه ضبابيه
ويعلن نائب رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
مالك عقار رفض مبادره الاتحاد الافريقي
لحل الازمه ويصف مبادره بمبادره احت ويقول
انها تسعى لادخال قوات دوليه الى السودان
وجعل منطقه الخرطوم منزوعه السلاح لم يخفي
عقار تحفظه على رئاسه كينيا للجنه الايجاد
واتهمها بعدم الحياد وقال ان الايجاد تسعى
لتكوين حكومه في المنفى يكون مقرها كينيا
للضغط على السودان للموافقه على مبادرتها
قال عقار ان الشعب السوداني التف حول
الجيش وقيادته ويرفض اي تسويه مع الدعم
السريع ويرى في الجيش الملاذ الامن اذا
يبدو من خلال كلام مالك عقار ان هناك حاجه
الى بدائل لصيغ الحوار ومقترحات الحل
المطروحه حاليا لا يعرف بالتحديد كم من
الوقت سيحتاج اليه الوسطاء لتجاوز العقبات
التي منعت تحقيق اي تقدم نحو الحل اما في
الميدان فالمتحاربون لا ينتظرون فقد شهدت
الخرطوم وام درمان قصفا جويا ومدفعيا
كثيفا استهدف مواقع لقوات الدعم السريع
ودارت مواجهات في مدينه الابيض عاصمه
ولايه شمال
وحسب المشروع تحديد وتجميع البيانات في
مناطق النزاع قتل اكثر من 2000 شخص في
عموم السودان منذ اندلاع المواجهات واذا
كانت الخرطوم ابرز بؤر الحرب فان اقليم
دارفور هو بؤرتها الثانيه تقول الامم
المتحده ان 1200 شخص قتلوا في الجنينه
عاصمه غرب دارفور وامام تعثر جهود الوساطه
واستمرار القتال يزداد الافق قتامه
بالنسبه للسودانيين وتتعقد الاوضاع
الانسانيه بالنسبه الى كثير منهم ويتوسع
النزوح واللجوء في ظروف صعبه جدا
معنى هنا في استوديو الحصاد الدكتور اسامه
دروس الكاتب السوداني المختص في الشؤون
السياسيه والعسكريه اهلا وسهلا
واذا اسامه لماذا رفضت المبادرات
الافريقيه
هي ملاحظات من الدوله السودانيه لانه لا
يمكن ان تقول انك ترفض كل شيء يعني هم
يرفضون اشياء محدده
الاتحاد الافريقي مثلا يجمد عضويه السودان
[موسيقى]
ومنذ البدايه
كان رد حكومه السودان انه على الاقل
تقدموا خطوه في فك تجميد عن عضويه السودان
حتى يمكن بعد ذلك ان تتحدثوا عن محاوله
للوساطه محاوله لايقاف الحرب وغيرها
بالاضافه لانه الطرح نفسه غير واضح يعني
ما الذي يريده هو كما تعلم الاتحاد
الافريقي له قانون معين فيما يخص
الانقلابات العسكريه وحتى تكون هناك حكومه
مدنيه وفقا الاسس الديمقراطيه المعروفه
فهو يعلق العضويه ويفعل ذلك مع كل دوله
ليس امرا افهم ذلك افهم ذلك لكن يعني في
ظل تعليق العضويه لا يمكن ان نقول انهم
يتدخلون في في الشان السوداني بشكل يمكن
ان يحمي مصالح الدوله السودانيه لانه
الدوله السودانيه غائبه عن الاتحاد
الافريقي نفسه الشيء الثاني ايجاد نفسها
تتكون من مجموعه من الدول القريبه جدا من
السودان متشابكه المصالح في السودان
الاعتراض في الايجاد على رئاسه كينيا
للجنه
العلاقات التي تربط بين كينيا او الرئيس
الكيني والقوات الدعم السريع والحديث عن
حتى استثمارات مشتركه بينه وبين قائد
الدعم السريع والاستعجال في اصدار
القرارات بشان السودان دون التشاور مع
حكومه السودان هنا كاسئله تطرح اذا ما كان
رفضت مساعي الامم المتحده وفولكر المبعوث
الاممي رفض واذا ما رفضت مساعي الايجاد
ورفض مساء رفضت مسائل الاتحاد الافريقي
فما الذي سوف يقبل اذا وحتى الوساطه
الامريكيه السعوديه الان المسؤولون
الامريكيون يقولون انها يعني توقفت هذه
المحادثات لانها لم تخرج بصيغه المطلوبه
السؤال هو ما الذي قدمته هذه الوساطات
كلها لحل النزاع في السودان هل هي فعلا
ايجابيه في حل هذا النزاع الحاصل
الان في السودان هل هي ايجابيه في ايقاف
الحرب هل هي في ايجابيه في الحفاظ على
المواطنه السوداني على المدنيين في
السودان هل تقدم شيئا يعني مثلا هذا
الحديث الذي يدور عن يعني اشياء خياليه
منطقه عاصمه خاليه من من القوات منزوعه
السلاح تدخل اممي يعني هذه الاشياء غريبه
جدا اذا كنت تريد ان تنزع السلاح في
الخرطوم وتجعلها منطقه منزوعه السلاح
وتنزل فيها قوات امميه هل ستفعل ذلك ايضا
في الجنينه هل ستفعل ذلك في دارفور هل
تريد احتلال السودان بقوات بديله حتى تحل
النزاع ولكن اذا ما رفضت كل هذه المبادرات
وقيل انها لا تقدم شيئا فما هي افاق الحل
الحسم العسكري يقال انه سياتي قريبا منذ
اكثر من شهرين ولكن ذلك لم يحدث هو ليس
ليس هنالك شيء اسمه قريب او بعيد الحرب في
اثيوبيا استمرت ولم يتدخل احد في الشان
الاثيوبي وترك للحكومه الاثيوبيه تثبيت
سيادتها وحقها في في السياده على اراضيها
ولم يتدخل احد السؤال الان لماذا يتدخلون
بكل هذه
الزخم من المبادرات التي لا ليس منها ولا
واحده
تجد حل حقيقي او توصيف حقيقي للمشكله في
السودان شكرا دكتور اسامه
الاكاديمي السوداني المختص في الشونه
السياسيه والعسكريه شكرا
ومعنا من السفيره السوزان بيجنائبه مساعده
وزير الخارجيه لامريكيه السابق للشؤون
الافريقيه والمستشاره السابقه للمبعوث
الامريكي الخاصه للسودان السيده سوزان بيج
ما الذي يقصده المسؤولون الامريكيون عندما
يقولون ان المحادثات في جده توقفت لانها
لان الامر لم يخرج بالصيغه المطلوبه فما
هي الصيغه المطلوبه وما هي الصيغه
المرفوضه
نعم شكرا على الاستضافه اعتقد ان ما تحاول
ان تقوله الحكومه الامريكيه انه ما دام
هنالك طرف او طرف القوات العسكريه يستمران
برفض القياده قياده هذه الوساطه واي جهد
للتوسط
من اجل انهاء القتال فبالتالي من الصعب
عليهم ان يكون هنالك اي تقدم بالتالي
والمسؤولين المسؤولون يحاولون ان ياتوا
بمقترحات اخرى للمضي قدما
ماذا يمكن ان تكون هذه المقترحات في رايك
ماذا يمكن ان يدفع بالامور الى الامام
اعتقد ان هنالك خيارات اخرى
اليها الولايات المتحده سواء كانت
الولايات المتحده قد تحاول ان تقوم
باكمال اجراءات
السفير الامريكي الى السودان او انه قد
يكون هنالك ربما
مبعوث اخر لكن اعتقد انه يجب ان يبدا
بالتفكير حول كيفيه التحدث مع المدنيين
الذين نرغب ان نراهم يتولون السلطه في
السودان بعد التوصل الى الاعتراف ان
العسكر ليس لديهم مكان في الحكومه السكان
السودان بل يجب ان يكون هنالك حكومه مدنيه
تطبق المبادئ الديمقراطيه الى اي مدى هذا
الكلام قريب من الواقع لان يعني ليس
المدنيين من يقررون الان ولكن الاله
العسكريه والعسكريون هم الذين يقررون ما
يحدث على الارض فما الجدوى من الحديث الى
المدنيين وما الذي يمكن ان يقصد به
نعم نعم انت محاق لكن اذا لم يكن هنالك اي
ضغط اخر واذا لم يكن هنالك اي شيء اخر واي
حل اخر يحصل فبالتالي نحن نسمح للقوات
المسلحه ولقوه السلاح ان تسيطر ولا اعتقد
ان هذا ما يرغب به الشعب السوداني اذا ما
استطعنا ان ندفع
بالمدنيين الذين يقومون
بالجزء الاكبر من العمل مثلا تقديم
المساعدات وتوفير المساعده اللي عن طريقي
للمجتمعات عن طريق المنظمات الاخرى يجب ان
يكون هنالك حوار مع الدول مع دول مثلا
الولايات المتحده والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه واطراف اخرى ولكن هذا الحوار ما
جدواه المدنيه الذي لا يحمل بندقيه لا
يستطيع ان يغير اي شيء على الارض
فليس يعني مفهوما تماما ما الذي يمكن ان
يكون وراء هذا الحوار
نقول انه ليس لديهم اسلحه هذا صحيح لا
يحملون الاسلحه لكن اذا ما استطاع الجيش
ان يرى ان الحوار يحصل وان الاتفاقات يتم
التوصل اليها مع اطراف اخرى خارج القوات
المسلحه بالتالي قد يكون هنالك ضغط مسلط
على الجيش
السفيره سوزن بيج نائبه مساعده وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه السابق للشؤون
الافريقيه والمستشاره السابقه للمبعوث
الامريكي الخاص الى السودان شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ومع
احتدام المعارك على الجبهه الجنوبيه جسر
حيوي يدخل قائمه الاهداف الاوكرانيه اذا
اتهمت
اتهمت سلطات المواليه لروسيا القوات
الاوكرانيه باستهداف جسر يربط شبه جزيره
القرم بمقاطعه خيرسون وياتي هذا في وقت
قال فيه وزير الدفاع
ان القوات الاوكرانيه بدات بتقليص نشاطها
بعد حوالي اسبوعين من الهجوم المضاد لكنه
اكد ان لدى القوات الاوكرانيه امكانيات
تكفي للقيام بمزيد من الاعمال الهجوميه
ضربات توصف بالموجعه تحاول القوات
الاوكرانيه توجيهها في الخطوط الخلفيه
للقوات الروسيه جنوبا
هذا جسر شونجر الرابط بين القرم وخيرسون
وتقول السلطات المواليه لروسيا ان سبب هذه
الحفره في الجسر كان صواريخ من طراز ستورم
شادول البريطانيه الصنع اطلقتها القوات
الاوكرانيه هي الضربه الاولى التي توجه
للجسر منذ بدء الحرب اما اهميته فتاتي من
كونه احد اهم طرق الامداد العسكري الروسي
من القرمي الى جبهات القتال في خيرسون
وهناك
ركزت القوات الاوكرانيه هجماتها مؤخرا
فيما اطلق عليه اسم الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد
سلطات خرسون المواليه لروسيا قللت من
اهميه ما وقع بالحديث عن وجود طريقين
اخرين يربطان خرسون بالقرم في اشاره الى
وجود بدائل لطرق الامداد اما توقيت الضربه
فياتي مع حديث وزير الدفاع الروسيه عن
تقليص القوات الاوكرانيه عملياتها على خط
المواجهه والعمل على تجميع صفوفها ويتزامن
مع ما قاله الرئيس الاوكراني من ان التقدم
بطيء جنوبا ودون المامول
اذا جسر شونكر هدف يدخل قائمه الاهداف
الاوكرانيه في معركه الجنوب حيث تسعى لضرب
الخطوط الخلفيه للقوات الروسيه لقلب
معادله المعركه على ما يبدو ففي غضون شهر
واحد تقريبا تحدث الاوكرانيون عن ضربات
لمواقع ومنشات روسيه حيويه مثل استهداف
مقر عسكري روسي في ميناء مدينه بيرج يانسك
وتفجير مستودع ذخيره روسي بمنطقه جنوبيه
هيرسون تمتد الضربات الاوكرانيه وصولا الى
القرب حيث تحدث الروس عن اعتراضهم مؤخرا
لصواريخها ومسيرات اطلقتها القوات
الاوكرانيه باتجاه مواقع ومناطق مختلفه في
شبه جزيره القرم وفي الحديث عن هذه
الضربات لابد من الاشاره الى الصواريخ
الغربيه التي تحوزها القوات الاوكرانيه
مثل هاي مارس الامريكيه وستون شادو
البريطانيه استخدام الصواريخ الغربيه له
خطوط حمر رسمها الروس اذ هدد وزير الدفاع
الروسي ان استهدفت بها الاراضي الروسيه او
شبه جزيره القرم فان الرد سيكون بضربات
فوريه لمراكز صنع القرار الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
في هذه الاثناء قال الرئيس الاوكراني
انه لا يستبعد ان تكرر روسيا ما فعلته في
سدك خوفك في محطه النوويه واضاف زيلينسكي
في تصريحهم للجزيره ان على من وصفهم
بحلفاء بلاده ان يتحركوا سريعا لتفادي اي
عمل ارهابي حسب ما وصفه في المحطه
كل تصريحات التي ادليت بها للصحافه
العالميه ومع الحلفاء اشرت فيها الى
الموضوع جهاز الاستخبارات ام الداني
بالمعلومات والتفاصيل حول ضروره تحرك
شركائنا على وجه السرعه لا نريد ان نمنح
الروس اي فرصه لاعاده ما فعلوه في سد
كخوفكا فهذا الامر الان اشد خطرا لانها
مساله امن نوويه ليس لبلدنا فحسب بل
للعالم اجمع
والمتحدث باسم زياره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
ومن موسكو سوف يكون معنا اندرويد فرولو
والمحلل السياسي والعسكري ابدا منك
[موسيقى]
ما الذي يقصده الرئيس زيلينسكي عندما
يتحدث عن احتمال ان تقوم روسيا بما وصفه
بهجمات ارهابيه في ذابولوجيا في تصريحه
الذي ادلى به للجزيره
[موسيقى]
مساء الخير
عندما تحدث رئيسنا سيد زيلينسكي عن احتمال
تهديدا محتمل لروسيا لمصنع
والذي نعرف انه ثاني اكبر مصنع في
اوروبا يعتمدوا في حديثه عن معلومات
استخباراتيه متوفره لديه والسبب اننا
نحاول ان ننبه الاخرين لهذا الامر وتعطي
سلطاتنا هذه المعلومات لكل شركائنا ولكل
المنظمات الدوليه لاننا نريد ان نتفادى
السيناريو حصل خلال الهجمه الارهابيه على
سديكا خوفكا نحن نامل ان الان المجتمع
الدولي لديه مؤشرات واضحه عن هذا التهديد
اللي هجمه ارهابيه نوويه قد تسبب انفجار
في مصنع
زبروجيا وشركائنا في المجتمع الدولي عليهم
ان يتخذوا كل الاجراءات الضروريه
لاقناع روسيا لعدم القيام بهذا الامر
بالاثناء هناك اتهام من القوات المواليه
لروسيات ت القوات الاوكرانيه بانها استخدم
استهدفت جسرا يربط اخرسون بشبه جزيره
القرم وحتى حددوا ان الاوكرانيين استخدموا
صواريخ
شادو
البريطانيه هل هذا ما قام به الاوكرانيون
فعلا وماذا يمكن ان يكون تاثيره
بدايه ارغب بالقول بان
حان الوقت لايقاف
ثقتنا بالمعلومات التي تعطيها روسيا هم
يكذبون كل يوم نحن نرى وانت ترى والكل
بصطاعته ان يراهم يختلقون العديد من
الامور اما بالنسبه للانفجار على ذلك
الجسر الذي اشرت اليه فان
رئيس هيئه الاركان المشتركه لم يقم باي
تصريح حول هذا الامر ورئيس الاستخبارات لم
يقل شيئا عن هذا الامر نحن نعرف مثلا انه
في القرن هنالك حركه مقاومه فعاله جدا
بالتالي قد يكون هم من قام بهذا الامر ما
علينا ان نفهمه انه ايا كان من وراء هذا
الامر هذا الهجوم على الجسر فان النتائج
بسيطه عمليه خطوط الامدادات لروسيا قد تم
اتلافها وتدميرها لانها لانهم الان لا
يستطيعون العبور الى منطقه خرس عبر ذلك
جسر عليهم ان يلتفوا حول هذه المنطقه وهي
اكثر تزيد
بمسافه 150 كيلومتر بالتالي الامر جيد
بالنسبه لنا انه تم تدمير خطوط الامدادات
تلك حسنا ابقى معنا سيد
بل اشكرك اذا شكرا لك
مستشار وزير الدفاع والمتحدث باسم وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه سيد
[موسيقى]
معنى من موسكو وهو محلل سياسي وعسكري اذا
سيد فرولوف
هل
تعتقد ان في نيه روسيا فعلا ان تقوم بعمل
عسكري ما في
عمل الارهابي كما يصفه الرئيس الاوكراني
فلودي
ان الرئيس زيلينسكي ونظامه الان هم نظام
ارهابي وهم يقومون بكل شيء لانهم كل شيء
اذا طبيعه ارهابي لانهم قاموا بتدمير
الكثير من الجسور وايضا بالتالي كل
المعلومات التي تخرج من كييف هي فقط جهد
لاطاله عمرها السياسيه لان كيف الان تخسر
المعركه في
جبهات القتال بالتالي مثل هذه التهم
الاتهامات غير صحيحه لان من غير المنطقي
ان تقوم روسيا باستهداف اي منشاه نوويه
الامر في غايه السخف في حقيقه الامر ماذا
عن هذا الجزء الذي كان يربط خيرسون بشبه
جزيره القرم من له والمصلحه في تفجيره وما
هي هذه هي المصلحه
سنعود الان
هنالك حقيقه ان الجسر تم استهدافه من قبل
صاروخ
الاوكرانيه وهو من اجل يهدفوا الى قطع
خطوط الامدادات الروسيه الى القرن اذا
يعني تمكن الاوكرانيون من تحقيق هدف عسكري
وتم قطع الامدادات للقوات الروسيه
لم يتمكنوا من قطع كل خطط الامدادات لكنهم
يحاولون ان يقوموا بعمليات تخريب
واستهداف للمناطق من اجل
اعطائي عمليات العسكريه الروسيه في
المنطقه عدا عن ذلك ماذا يمكن ان تكون
اثار تفجير هذا الجسر الذي كما ذكرت شبه
جزيره القرم بخير
اذا الفكره بسيطه للغايه
وزير الدفاع شوي جو قال انه اذا ما
استخدمت اوكرانيا اوكرانيا استخدمت مثل
هذه الصواريخ مثل
فوق المناطق العمليات العسكريه سيعني هذا
الامر ان الولايات المتحده ستكون جزءا من
هذا الصراع وان روسيا سترد
باستخدام طرق اخرى شكرا جزيلا لك من موسكو
اندرو فرول محلل السياسي والعسكري الروسي
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان الشراكه
بين بلاده والهند هي الاكثر اهميه وباتت
اشد دينيه اكثر من اي وقت مضى واضاف في
مؤتمر صحفي جمعه مع رئيس الوزراء الهنديرا
مودي ان المحادثات تناولت القضايا الملحه
بدوره قال مودين القرارات التي اتخذت خلال
لقائه بايدن اضافت فصلا جديدا للشراكه
الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين البلدين على حد
وصفه
وفي ملف العلاقات الهنديه الامريكيه سيكون
لنا حديث معمق بعد قليل يناقش اولويات
اداره بايدن في خضم انتقادات للسجل الهندي
الحقوقي
[موسيقى]
في تطورات عمليه البحث عن الغواصه
المفقوده قال قائد منطقه خفر السواحل
الامريكيه انهم عثروا على بقايا تطابق
الغواصه وهي تشير الى ان الغاطسه انفجرت
من الداخل وكانت وسائل اعلام امريكيه نقلت
عن اوشن جيت الشركه المشغله للغواصه
المفقوده فقدانها طاقم الغواصه السياحيه
وكان الاتصال مع الغواصه انقطع عصر الاحد
بعد ساعه وخمسه واربعين دقيقه من انطلاقها
في رحله غوص تستغرق ساعتين ونصف الساعه
لتفقد حطام السفينه تايتنك الشهيره
معنى من واشنطن مراسل الجزيره ناصر
الحسيني مره اخرى نسمع عن تايتنك التي
خلدها الفيلم الشهير هناك تفاصيل كثيره
ولكن اذا ما كان بامكانك ناصر ان توضح لنا
ما يحدث بالضبط
بعد هذا بالضبط الان اننا امام ماساه
حقيقيه هو جاء الان هذا الحديث على لسان
السلطات الامريكيه خفض السواحل اكدوا اذا
فقدان تلك الغواصه لنسميها ربما الكبسوله
من سطح الماء الى قاع البحر حيث ترقد
سفينه التايتنك التاريخيه عمليه نزول
والهبوط ببطء تستغرق حوالي ساعتين ونصف
وبالتالي هي عمليه فنيه جد معقده اولئك
الباحثون لاستكشافيون من تلك الشركه ودفع
كل واحد منهم 250 الف دولار كي ياخذ
ويغامر بنفسه نحو الاعماق
نزلوا بالفعل في الوقت المحدد يبدو انهم
نزلوا نحو قاع البحر نحو موقع سفينه
تايتنك التاريخيه دون مشاكل تذكر لكن هنا
انقطع الاتصال في فتره ما قبل يومين وبدات
تساؤلات ماذا حدث ماذا حدث الان لدينا
جواب على لسان السلطات الامريكيه حدث
انفجار داخلي في تلك الكبسوله او الغواصه
الصغيره التي لا تحمل اكثر من خمسه اشخاص
وهذا
الانفجار الداخلي ربما يعتقدون في هذه
الفتره من تحقيقات انه حدث نوع من الشرخ
داخل الجسم تلك الغواصه الصغيره
تحت عمق يبلغ حوالي 20 الف قدم نحو قاع
المحيط وبالتالي الضغط الشديد الان لنا
خبراء يتحدثون عن كيفيه الوفاه واضح جدا
انهم توفوا كاملا اذا ما كنت داخل تلك
الغواصه في عمق المحيط نحو قاع البحر كل
هذا الظلمه ليست هناك اي نور ووصلت بالفعل
الى قرب التايتنك لن ترى شيئا كله ظلام
وبمجرد ان يحصل ذلك الانفجار الداخلي فان
الوفاه تتم في اقل من ثانيه في جزيئات
الثانيه وبالتالي يعتقد الان على نطاق
واسع انهم لم يتمكنوا من العيش سيست البحث
بطبيعه الحال وستستمر التحقيقات وهناك عده
تساؤلات ما الذي يتسبب في هذا الانفجار
الداخلي يبدو انه النوع المعدن الفايبر
الذي استخدم في بناء تلك الغواصه يبدو انه
يمكن استخدامها مره او مرتين نحو الاعماق
لكن ليس اكثر من مره او مرتين هذه كلها
كانت رحله تجريبيه المغامرون الخمسه ومعهم
الخمسه وهو قائد المركبه كانوا يدركون
تماما حجم الاخطار ووقعوا على قرارات مع
الشركه السياحيه بانهم ربما يتعرضون
لاخطار شديده منها الوفاء وبالتالي كانوا
يدركون تماما حجم المخاطر ولذلك قبل قليل
فقط الشركه الشركه المالكه للغواصه اشادت
بروح المغامره والاستكشاف التي كان يتمتع
بها الرجال الخمسه الان اسم ستستمر
التحقيقات لانه تم العثور على حطام هذه
المركبه في جزئين على بعد حوالي 200 متر
من السفينه التايتنك هي التيتانيك غرقت
1912 الان في 2023 نفس ماساه تتكرر لكن
بارقام اقل شكرا جزيلا لك من واشنطن مراسل
الجزيره ناصر الحسيني
[موسيقى]
ينتظر الاف من سكان قطاع غزه دورهم في
قرعه الحج لكل عام خصوصا كبار السن فمنهم
من حالفه الحظ بعد طول انتظار ومنهم من لا
يزال ينتظر دوره وقد اعلنت وزاره الاوقاف
في غزه ان عدد المسجلين للحج بلغ نحو
ثلاثه واربعين الف شخص في حين ان حصه حجاج
القطاع تبلغ نحو 2005
والنعمه لا يرى الملك
[موسيقى]
لا
صفحه جنديه ثمانيه من غزه امضت سنوات
عمرها وهي تنتظر فرصه لاداء الحج لكنها لم
تؤدي الفريضه بعد بسبب نظام القرعه
لاختيار الحجاج
يا الله يا الله اصيبت قبل عامين بجلطه
دماغيه افقدتها الحركه والنطق وبعد
تعافيها عاودها الامل مجددا لاداء الحج
هذا العام ايضا لكنه لم يتحقق
وانا بدري والله يمكن تعبت عليها كتير
والله تعبت كتير بقول مش ندامه مش ندامه
بس نشوف الحبيب محمد
اللهم لبيك فاداء الفريضه حلم يراود عشرات
الالاف من سكان قطاع غزه حالهم حاله بقيه
المسلمين لكن لفلسطين عدد محدد من الحجاج
ولقطاع غزه نسبه منه ولذلك تجري الجهات
المختصه قرعه للمتقدمين الى الحج لترتيب
اجراءات سفرهم
قدموا شركات السياحه الدينيه خدمات السفر
والاقامه والارشاد للحجاج قبل السفر وخلال
مناسك
الحجركم ونطمن اهالي الحجاج ان هذا الموسم
سيكون باذن الله حافلا بالعطاءات حافلا
بالانجازات بالرغم انه سيكون الاعمار يعني
ما بين السبعين والثمانين سيكون علينا حمل
كبير
والله وانا فرحان والله لكن هذا الحمل
بالنسبه الى ابي نهاد وزوجته لا يبدو
ثقيلا بعد ان فاز بقرعه الحج لهذا العام
لسنوات عده انتظرها هذه اللحظه فالزوجه
اصيبت بمرض السرطان منذ خمس سنوات
والمخاوف زادت منذ ذلك الحين بان يطول
الانتظار وان لا يتمكن من اداء الفريضه ما
شاء الله ما احلى ريحتك الحمد لله رب
العالمين الا الله الله سبحانه وتعالى
اكرمني بعد 14 سنه وانا بسجل دائما وبقول
يا رب يا رب يا رب وزوجتي مرضت كمان
فهذه الاسره التي تستعد للحج ومئات مثلها
تقابلها مراره انتظار الاف اخرين لمواسم
حج مقبله قد تطول لسنوات ويبقى حجاج قطاع
غزه عالقين بين مشقه السفر وارتفاع تكلفه
الحج وعقبات اخرى كثيره سببها استمرار
الحصار المفروض على قطاع غزه منذ سنوات
هبه كيلا الجزيره من قطاع غزه
[موسيقى]
نعود الى ملف العلاقات الامريكيه الهنديه
في ضوء زياره رئيس الوزراء الهندي الى
واشنطن حيث تتهم الاداره الامريكيه تتهم
بالامتناع يعني اثاره وضع حقوق الانسان مع
رئيس الوزراء الهندي بسبب الشراكات
المتناميه بين البلدين والترتيبات الجيو
السياسيه في اسيا ضد الصين خاصه الهند
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه عضواني
بارزان في تحالف كواد الى جانب استراليا
واليابان وهو تكتل المناهض لنفوذ بيجين
يخدم مصلحه يدلهي التي طالما اشتكت من
سلوك الصين المتغطرسه على حدودها كما
ينتمي البلدان الى ما يسمى مجموعه اي تو
يو تو المعنيه بالاستثمارات المشتركه
والمبادرات في مجالات المياه والطاقه
والنقل والقضاء والصحه والامن الغذائي
وتضم كذلك اسرائيل والامارات العربيه
المتحده وتعتبر الشراكه الدفاعيه
والتكنولوجيه رافعه اخرى للعلاقات الثنا
بعد موافقه بايدن على السماح لشركه جنرال
الكتريك الامريكيه لتصنيع محركاتها في
الهند مع شركه هندستان
للصناعات الجويه والتابعه للدوله وتستفيد
واشنطن ايضا من نزاع الهندي مع الصين
باستخدام حجم الهند الدفاعي في ردع بيجين
على الحدود وفي المحيط الهندي فضلا عن
استخدام نفوذ وجلهي في المؤسسات الدوليه
من واشنطن ينضم الينا
مديره الاتصالات والاعلان في حمله الرئيس
بير كلينتن ومدير مكتب الرئيس جو بايدن
عندما كان سيناتورا سيد برجر اهلا وسهلا
بك الشراكه الامريكيه الهنديه وفق السياقه
الراهن استراتيجيا الى اي مدى هي مهمه
للبلدين
زياره اليوم الى البيت الابيض من قبل رئيس
وزراء مودي تعتبر مهمه بشكل حساس
لان السيد مودي هو شريك مهم جدا
نظرا لان الدوله جار له الصين هي رغم انها
ما زالت شريك تجاري معنا لكن هناك
احتكاكات كثيره ما زالت قائم بين الولايات
المتحده والصين وان زياره هذا الاسبوع
لملاحظات الرئيس
بايتن هذا الاسبوع حول وصفه الرئيس الصيني
بانه ديكتاتور ولكن هذه الزياره مهمه كما
قال التقريركم فهي عظم الاكواد وهي مجموعه
اساسيه
الدفاع والدبلوماسيه
لحمايه استراليا واليابان والهند
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبالتالي
اعتقد ان هذا هذه زياره يستكون اجتماعا
مثمرا ونقاشات مفيده مع رئيس الوزراء ولكن
اعتقد ان مشاكله في مساله حقوقنا ستبقى
تلاحقه اين تلاحقه اينما ذهب
نتابع جزءا من هذه الكلمه لرئيس الوزراء
الهندي رانجرا مودي امام الكونغرس
الامريكي
في اوكرانيا
الذي زعزعه امناء اوروبا
ويسبب الاما عديده في المنطقه
والنتائج ليست جيده
البلدان الجنوب تاثرت
ايضا رئيس الوزراء الهندي يلقي خلي الان
امام الكونغرس السيد بولجر كيف ستنعكس هذه
الشراكه على الوضع في المحيطين الهندي
والهادي مع تنامي التوتر مع الصين التي لا
يخفى على احد علاقه التحدي
بينها وبين الهند
هذه في الواقع شيء انا سابقا ذكرته هو ان
هذه من المهم جدا ان الولايات المتحده
يكون لديه شريك راغب
يرغب بالوقوف امام الصين وهذا ما فعلته
الهند فالهند قوه نوويه ولديها واحد فاصل
اربعه مليار من السكان وهي اكبر ديمقراطيه
في العالم
واننا نعتبر ذلك يعتبر شيئا مهما جدا
بالنسبه لحليف لنا
يمكن دافع عنه ويمكن نحن ان ندافع عنهم
اذا ما اذا حصلت اي مشاكل وبشكل خاص في
منطقه المحيط الهادي محيط الهادي الهندي
هذه الواقيع يعتبر حقيقه اساسيه ومهمه انه
الولايات المتحده ينبغي عليه من يتعاونا
بشكل جيد سويه
سجل رئيس وزراء الهند في ملف حقوق الانسان
وفق الخارجيه الامريكيه نفسها به انتهاكات
عديده في الحريات الدينيه لكن الرئيس
بايدن استقبل رئيس الوزراء الهندي ولم يكن
لهذا الامر حضور في اجتماعهم
الرئيس الوزراء مودي فعلا ولاول مره قام
بشيء وهذا امر يمكن ان يكون
تغطيه المتحده والمؤتمر الصحفي لاول مره
وافق على استقبال الاسئله من وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه وبالتالي هو طبعا ناور
ولم يجاوب بشكل مباشر ويقال انه ليس هناك
اي تمييز عنصري او ديني او عرقي او قومي
خلال كل الهند ولكن ذلك هو
[موسيقى]
من انتهاكات الصين ضد المسلمين الايجور
على سبيل المثال وهو امر يحظى بتركيز
امريكي دون ان يكون هناك اي استنكار في
المقابل
للانتهاكات بحق المسلمين في الهند
اعتقد هنا نجد انه وزاره الخارجيه عليهما
ان يتحدث بنفس الصوت ونفس الصيغه
التمييز يبغى يسمى باسمه واعتقد رئيس
الوزراء مودي وعلى ما قام به تعود الى عام
واعتقد ان البيت الابيض
اساسا ينظر الى
تحقق من نشاطات حاليه اكثر ولكنه قال
البيت الابيض قال بانهم سوف
يحاسبون اي بلد مهما كان اذا فعل ذلك اعلن
ننتظر كيف سيتحقق ذلك اثناء هذه السياره
وربما حتى دعوه العشاء مع هذا المساء في
البيت الابيض
باختصار هل تعتقد الولايات المتحده ستحقق
مكاسب فيما يخص علاقه الهند بالصين
من وجهه نظر
التجاريه للامور
ان التجاره الهنديه او العلاقه التجاريه
بين الهند والولايات المتحده قويه جدا
فهناك
الكثير راس المال الفكري وهنا كثير من
التصنيع
وعلاقات تجاريه قويه جدا ايضا وكذلك لدينا
مثل هذا العلاقات مع الصين بناء على كل
منتجات من الايفون الى الى
الاشياء الاخرى التي تنتج نتيجه الشراكه
بين الصين لايت متحده ولكن من المفيد
للولايات المتحده عندما تعامل مع الصين
انه لو لو كان هناك ضروره وحاجه
لتصنيع اكبر للملابس والانسجه فيمكن
الاستعانه بالهند
كبديل عن جزيلا لك